would you come up with this idea we all
get really generated from the FA made
some changes
airplanes historically have been kept
away from the public and the FAA is now
opening that up to make flying much more
accessible and much more fun to anyone
who wants to fly so a new Catterick
called light sport and a new license
call this poor pilot okay but this
sounds like a disaster waiting to happen
because anybody can go buy an airplane
and slide at the skies I mean there's
got to be completely different rules of
the air there
well actually what they've done is it's
a brilliant set of regulations which
allows you to have access to kind of
flying that you could safely be trained
and have AI easy access to for instance
the sport flying you don't fly at night
and you don't flying in just at air
space you don't fly in bad weather so
with that limitation we can now expand
the training and give you more training
to make you safely and easily be able to
fly your own personal plane give us the
specs about the plane range and
everything yeah the right place about
100 miles an hour flies about four or
five hundred miles burns 25 miles
I guess about 20 miles a gallon it's
amphibious land or water effectively the
airplane is designed to give you an
amazing life experience of course
everybody who's dreamed of flying he
says look I have always wanted to fly
but have my own plane our objective is
to make that more possible make an
airplane that's intuitive easy fun and
very versatile so you need how many
hours of training then to fly this you
need about 20 hours of training 20 hours
of show you need yeah yeah on the
weekend right I can now start weekends
in a row would you be would you be but
do you want me behind behind the
controls of an airplane well I don't
know is it any more difficult than let's
say being behind the controls of an
automobile a little bit more right it
requires an FAA training so it's about
two weeks so think of it maybe it's
getting your advanced scuba license so
still very controlled and we will train
you this about in about two weeks it'll
be a life experience for you tell us
about the companies that built the
hardware that goes into all this because
I'm noticing there's also the screen
that looks very familiar to people that
have those screens in their automobiles
yeah if you look at the airplane what
you probably see is that it's pretty
unique and that what we've done is try
to the goal here is to democratize
aviation and how you do that how do you
democratize any tech
ecology is you humanizes so we've got
some of the world's best airplane
designers product designers boat
designers car designers put in the room
instead let's figure this out let's make
the world's first pure consumer poly
aircraft so so it's very intuitive and
very safe I'm just wondering that I
still wonder about the airspace right so
how do you know that you're not gonna
get in the way of other airplanes where
you can go you know like all of that
right well I'll give you some supplement
saying first of all the FAA doesn't do
things carelessly no this was 12 years
12 years in the making so this has been
thought through very very carefully the
fact that matter is the airspace is not
congested the airspace right around
major airports can get congested away
from that it's like public airspace
that's widely as broadly unutilized so
the FA recognizes this what altitude
'you are you prescribed
it's ten thousand ten thousand feet and
and and now below okay it's like the
off-road air space most most airliners
are up twenty thirty thousand right
we're just being made we're in
California start in Silicon Valley Palo
Alto the companies in Northern
California start we're starting
production now okay so what kind of
engine do you're using there it's a it's
a off Rotax engine for cycle hundred
horsepower and you've got how many
orders fifteen hundred it's about
fifteen hundred about four hundred
million in aircraft backlog put that
perspective I think Tesla the same point
had about nine hundred vehicle orders in
about a hundred million so we yeah I was
using the same Tesla driver is likely
gonna buy an airplane like this
potentially I mean again I mean I mean
this airplane have you've seen it but it
is it is for anybody he's gonna fly